SPEAKER: Mom to clump
over and become you.
Somehow, like, literally,
a piece of software
melded together,
fused, and then it
started to turn itself
into a living, breathing,
you know, like a
steak with a brain.
Like, you're meat that
grew up inside your mother.
You're like a wet-ware android.
And now, you're grasping
all this amazing information
as you map and model the world.
You're growing.
You're learning.
You're expanding.
You're slowly emerging
as a thinking being.
And it's like, oh my God, this
is what it's like to be a mind.
I mean, you're transcendent.
You're transcendent.
You're transcendent, but
you're also made of flesh.
So it's like, holding
you is like, what
is this actual piece
of divine miracle
that somehow this universe
allowed to organize.
It's insane.
Looking into your eyes actually
feels like looking at a galaxy.
It really does.